the national debate over transgenderism
and specifically transgenderism in
elementary and middle schools has
focused on three things
biology psychology and theology three
questions what is a woman what is gender
and who are we
but there's a fourth aspect that's
gotten very little attention and maybe
playing a larger role in this
transgender phenomenon than most people
seem to know money
who's paying
when the white house promoted puberty
blockers for little kids last week
transgender transitioning for little
kids
the study that the white house cited as
the scientific basis for this program
came from a group called the trevor
project
the trevor project is an lgbt non-profit
organization funded by the donations of
individuals and corporations now
according to a new report from chuck
ross at the washington free beacon
turns out two of the corporations that
fund the trevor project are ab vi
and allergan pharmaceutical companies
that make the drugs and medical products
that are used in the transgender
transitioning process
both companies gave at least fifty
thousand dollars to the trevor project
but the trevor project never disclosed
the donations they never disclosed the
obvious conflict of interest
the government's argument for
transitioning kids rests on a study
funded by the companies that most stand
to benefit from the government promoting
the transitioning of kids and they all
justify the medical experimentation on
little kids on the grounds that the
interventions will reduce the kids risk
of suicide when they get older
but it turns out that science is totally
bunk too
just a few years ago a group of
scientists including a physician who
participated in clinical research for
abvay
wrote in a letter for the journal of
clinical endocrinology
that the transgender drugs for kids
could cause sterility sexual dysfunction
and heart disease without any proof of
long-term success in suicide prevention
in other words
the white house is peddling child abuse
based on bunk science commissioned by a
left-wing non-profit funded by the
companies selling the child abuse we are
living in a time of unprecedented
upheaval economic social and political
people don't even know what a woman is
anymore
and even still at least one political
rule endures he who pays the piper calls
the tune did you like that clip i'm glad
even if you didn't like that clip
subscribe ring that bell get the
notifications also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
sign up for the michael knowles show
leave a five-star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]